Hey everyone. We're going to be looking at ...
taxes and subsidies and this is the first and the two parter ...
of how we distort market outcomes.
And when we look at these price distortions or these ...
market distortions, what we're going to see is ...
that they actually erode a lot of the wealth generation that ...
took place with voluntary transactions.
So with taxes and subsidies, this is actually going to ...
impede any movement.
Not any movement, it's going to impede some of ...
the movement of our low valued assets moving to ...
higher valued uses.
So let's go ahead and jump into understanding taxes first ...
and then we'll get subsidies at the end.
And here we are back in taco land.  Guess what?
We're selling tacos for $4.  Everybody's happy.
There are no taxes that are being introduced into this.
So the market is going to clear the quantity Demand ...
just equals the quantity supplied.
Market is maximizing surplus.
And so everything is really great at this point.
But guess what, here comes the government.
The government says, you know what,
we got to put a $2 tax per taco here.
So what we're going to be doing is looking at this $4.
But here's the key question for us.
How much does the price increase?
How much does that price increase?
Because maybe that $2 tax doesn't actually raise that $4 taco to $6.
It might raise it to 450 or, or maybe $5 or maybe $5.50.
There is a little bit more behind understanding taxes ...
and how a per unit tax works.
But in this case, we're going to have tax ...
burden and tax incidents.
And what we mean by that is how that burden falls,
how that tax burden falls on to consumers and to producers.
Now let's look at what happens at a $4 taco.
We do put this $2 tax per taco on there.
And that's going to turn away some of the consumers in that market.
Now taxes also are a cost to the business.
They increase the cost of production.
So that's also going to hurt some of the production ...
process, which means there's less ...
tacos to go around because it's more costly to make those ...
tacos than when it was before.
So we are not only affecting consumers,
we're also going to be affecting our producers.
So we turn away some of the consumers inside this market,
but we still have some people who are willing to pay more ...
than, than the original $4 market ...
equilibrium price.
So let's see what happens when we do this.
Well, first of all,
look at here, our Mr.
Government official. He's very happy.
He's generating taco tax.
I don't really like the way that looks.
I don't like hearing about taco taxes.
But we are seeing that we do get tax revenue from our taco tax.
So tax revenue is just basically going to be the ...
amount of the tax.
In this case it was $2.
And you multiply that by how many tacos are being sold ...
because this is a per unit tax and that gives us our tax revenue.
Now one thing that we also need to consider is the fact of ...
this thing called deadweight loss.
Deadweight loss is lost welfare because we have ...
under consumption and underproduction inside the market.
The market would have enjoyed more surplus had ...
this tax not ever been introduced.
But because of the dead weight loss,
some people aren't getting tacos anymore.
So we have sad taco faces that are taking place.
Now look at, let's look at some of the ...
numbers behind how this is.
Here's our original.
Here's our original information.
We can see the market price going from $6 all the way down to $2.
Our quantity demand goes from 50 up to 90.
That follows what we call the loved man.
That is there's an inverse relationship between the ...
price of a good and the quantity sold.
And then the quantity supplied goes from 90 all the ...
way down to 50 as our price goes from $6 to $2.
This is the law of supply.
There's a positive or direct relationship between the ...
price of a good and the quantity inside that market.
Now we have excess demand and supply as our last column there.
And all we're doing is subtracting quantity demand ...
and quantity supplied.
So 50 minus 90 would actually be minus 40.
But I'm leaving it as an absolute value here.
And this just lets me know that I have a surplus because ...
my quantity supplied is greater than my quantity demand.
So that goes from 40 to 20 to 0.
And we can see at a market price of $4,
quantity demand equals quantity supply.
So that's where the market clears.
That is where people want to be.
Now as we move down to $3 and $2,
we see excess demand go from 20 to 40.
And in this case we have a shortage.
There are more people who are wanting to buy that good ...
than what is available.
So 80 minus 60, 90 minus 50.
But what happens when we introduce that tax?
Now look at this quantity supplied with the tax.
I mentioned earlier that the supply is also going to be ...
affected because it increases the cost of production.
So this actually lowers the amount that we are willing ...
and able to sell to consumers.
Now notice it goes from 70 to 60 to 50, 40 and 30.
So we failed by 20 at each possible market price.
Now what we want to do is find the new equilibrium ...
price, new equilibrium quantity,
the tax revenue and our deadweight loss.
Now to find our new market equilibrium price and ...
quantity, what we want to do is look at ...
our quantity demand here, look at our quantity supplied here.
And we Notice that at 60 here,
those two are equal at a price of $5.
So our old taco price was $4.
Our new taco price is $5.
That means we have only increased the price of tacos to $5.
But we had a $2 tax.
Okay, we're gonna get there.
In this case, let's look at our tax revenue.
So tax revenue is the amount that's being sold.
60 times the tax of $2.
And that gives us $120.
Now what does that mean?
Or how do we get to that $2 tax where the other,
other dollar go?
Well, the way that you are going to ...
find how much to charge to the consumer and how much ...
the producer actually receives is to look at the New ...
Market Price, $5 New Quantity or yeah,
I guess that would be the new quantity and equilibrium of 60.
And then what you want to do is compare it to the old ...
quantity supplied and what we see down here.
So find where 60 and 60 are together and we're going to ...
move over to that market price of $3.
So $5 minus $3 is the $2 tax that we've been talking about.
So we can see that the shifting of our quantity ...
supplied with that tax is going to lower the amount that we consume.
And that would have been equal to under no tax,
a $3 market price.
So we've accounted for the $2 that the tax that the ...
government tax, the taco market.
So now let's do deadweight loss again.
The under consumption sometimes could be the ...
overproduction leading to a loss in wealth.
Overproduction would occur if you have a subsidy there.
But what happens here is we're under consuming what we wanted.
We used to consume 70, now we only consume 60.
So that's a loss in tacos there.
And we're also being charged a higher price,
$5 instead of the $4.
The producers are receiving less because they only get $3.
They pay $1 of the tax and the consumers pay $1 of the tax.
That's tax incident incidents.
Who actually bears the burden of the tax?
We bear 50% as consumers.
The firms bear 50% as the producers.
Had something called elasticities been different,
then we could have seen that maybe the consumers pay ...
more or maybe the producers receive even less.
So then the burden would have shifted.
But let's calculate out the deadweight loss here.
So we are now consuming 60.
We used to consume 70.
So 70 minus 60 is going to give us 10.
And then we're going to multiply that by the difference ...
in the prices that we pay as consumers and as what the ...
producers now receive of three.
So we have 10 times two.
And because this is, if you're looking at this ...
graphically, so to speak,
you would find the area of a triangle.
And so that's going to give us one half base times the height.
And we have a deadweight loss of $10.
So overall, not good for us.
Now, another way to look at this is ...
to also ask the question, what tax rate is going to ...
cause some change inside this market?
So if I want to go from $4 to $5,
what tax rate gets me that here?
What we do is set up our equation to look like this.
Four times one plus the tax rate is equal to $5.
And I'm going to simplify this down.
So multiplying through, we get $4 plus 4 times T,
which is just tax written as t equals $5.
And then we're going to simplify this a little bit further.
So subtract four from both sides and we have four,
T equals one, which means our tax rate is ...
going to be equal to 25%.
Now, we could use this to figure ...
out where no new transaction is going to take place.
For example, so if I have a customer and ...
let's say a car dealer who are trying to negotiate a price,
and all of a sudden we have to throw in the tax.
Well, that tax rate can help us ...
figure out if the consumer no longer wants to purchase that ...
particular car.
But you would set it up like this to figure that out.
Now let's shift gears a little bit to subsidies.
We already saw how taxes can erode.
Well, they cause deadweight loss ...
and they shift.
They place burden onto consumers and producers.
Now, look at subsidies.
Surely this looks pretty good, right?
$2 taco subsidy.
You only pay $2.
We were paying four, so that's pretty good.
I mean, why wouldn't you want this?
How do subsidies potentially or absolutely erode wealth?
Well, here we are.
We're looking pretty.
I don't know, this person looks kind of sad.
Maybe they know something that we don't.
So let's look at how subsidies can hold harm wealth.
Here we have $2 taco subsidy only pay $2.
In this case, Maria's back at it.
She was selling $4.
But hey, everybody's,
hey, you know,
we got some people lined up.
They're like, all right,
$2, that's pretty good.
We'll go for that.
We'll go for that subsidy.
But that's just a few people.  What happens.
Whoa, look at all these people.
All of a sudden, this $2 taco subsea where we ...
don't have to pay $2 now, instead of the $4 means we ...
have people saying, I'll take three,
I'll take four, I'll take five.
You have the whole crowd of people who were not ...
participating in the market to begin with,
but now they automatically want to come into the market ...
because it's much cheaper for them.
Perhaps it got onto their willingness to pay.
So subsidies are actually moving higher value uses to ...
lower value uses.
We had people.
I think I said that right.
We have people who are not engaged in the market to begin with.
Now they are.
This means that. I don't know.
Let's find out.
This means that this is what we get.
We have a lot of people now that are over consuming.
Somebody's toupee came flying off of the taco there.
We have a lot of people who are now over consuming the ...
tacos, and this wouldn't have ...
happened and had we not had that subsidy.
So we actually have a distortion of wealth taking ...
place aside from just the over consumption.
We also have people looking at this,
wait a second, I gotta pay a subsidy fund so ...
Maria can sell $2 tacos.
These people don't look too very happy about doing this.
So maybe there's something else going on with subsidies.
We have over consumption, and we have people who are ...
worried that is this the best use of funds to go to ...
subsidizing tacos.
So what we get is, how do these subsidies affect wealth?
Well, subsidies lower the price.
More people buy it.
Overconsumption and waste take place.
We saw that the flying toupee overproduction also is going to occur.
So in this case, Maria was producing more ...
than she should have, more than she was able to produce.
And so, yeah,
we see that taking place.
Taxpayer burden.
Now we have people who are funding this subsidy,
funding these cheaper tacos.
And we're kind of curious if that's what we really want to do.
And then we have the inefficient resource use.
All right, Inefficient resource use.
Not every taco goes to someone who values it that ...
much. Okay?
Not Every taco.
I mean they, they didn't value the $4 taco,
which is, that's,
that's still what it is.
It's still a $4 taco, but they're getting it for $2.
So there wasn't enough value being placed on that taco to begin with.
And that's how our subsidies are actually affecting wealth.
So not only do taxes, which we can,
it's much easier for us to see how that affects wealth.
We also have subsidies affecting wealth because ...
they're distorting the market outcome as opposed to what ...
it would be just under voluntary transactions and trade.
So what are our key takeaways here?
Let's look at our key takeaways.
Taxes predict where taxes will kill demand.
We already saw that taxes will lower the amount that ...
consumers are willing and able to buy.
So if you can predict where taxes will kill demand,
you'll set your firm up in a better spot if possible.
Shift tax burden.
In this example here, we saw that we only had a $1 tax burden.
If you have an inelastic product,
that is, if the product that you are ...
selling people needed a lot, then they're not going to be ...
as responsive to price changes as to something that ...
people just kind of like.
We're going to look at an example here in a second.
So in that case, you can potentially shift that ...
tax burden away from you onto the consumer and ...
you're going to capture more of that surplus and then ...
advocate for better, better policy.
In this case, if you don't like the idea of ...
the tax being levied onto your firm,
advocate at the local, if it's a local tax burden,
or state or federal, depending on what level it ...
happens to be, to get a better policy put in place.
Subsidies expand production and subsidize.
It's going to distort wealth, but you are going to be able ...
to expand that production process,
target low value customers.
So you have a subsidy.
Now, I mean we,
we seen that it does distort wealth.
But if you're trying to turn a frown upside down,
target the low value customers and design ...
cheaper versions of that product. Product.
And so that way you can extract surplus from them as ...
well and then strategically capture the subsidy.
All right, strategically capture that subsidy.
So you're going to have, you're going to be looking at ...
ways that you can sell your product while using the ...
subsidy as a help there.
So look at, back at the taxes here.
Gas stations raise prices after a fuel tax,
but since customers still need gas,
they don't lose too many consumers.
So here you're able to shift some of that tax burden.
Meanwhile, luxury goods stores might ...
suffer badly from a luxury tax and push for exemptions in ...
the late 1980s or it might have been early 1990s.
I remember a luxury tax being placed on yachts and what ...
they found out is that it actually did not work.
Because what happened, people quit buying yachts or ...
buying bigger boats or whatever it was.
And the luxury tax, which was,
hey, we're going to target people ...
who can afford it, well,
they just quit buying it.
And so this, that,
that tax actually didn't work too well with the subsidies here.
The solar panel companies, they expanded massively ...
when government subsidies went for the,
they were doing the tax breaks or subsidizing the ...
green energy production.
And so here they were pricing aggressively to reach more ...
customers who otherwise wouldn't have bought bought them.
So that way they were strategically capturing that ...
subsidy and trying to take advantage of what they could.
All right, that is it.
Hope you have enjoyed it.
And we have one more on how on price distortions and ...
how they affect wealth.